[Musique]
il
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée
nouveauté cette semaine vos réactions
sur le télégramme d'ayrté france vous
pouvez prendre part au débat donner
votre opinion et interpeller nos invités
au sommaire de ce lundi 11 octobre le
malaise du corps enseignant revient sur
la table à six mois de la présidentielle
à l'origine une vidéo de l'agression
d'une enseignante par l'un de ses élèves
à combs-la-ville en région parisienne un
nouvel est filmée par un camarade de
classe alors qu'on s'apprête à
commémorer la mort de samuel pâtit
professeur décapité il ya quasiment un
an l éducation nationale a prévu un
temps en dommages vendredi prochain mais
l'initiative fait débat les profs sont
ils formés pour cela certains estiment
que non qu'en pensent les élèves pas
tous d'accord bref faut-il rendre
hommage à semelle pâti dans les
établissements depuis ce soir vous
pouvez donc prendre part à la discussion
en réagissant sur le conte télégramme rt
france
l'europe est-elle dans le déni de la
gravité de la crise énergétique une
enquête de mediapart semble en tout cas
la firme et après la hausse des prix du
gaz et d'électricité sur le vieux
continent études pointent du doigt la
décision bruxelles de traiter le marché
d'électricité comme un marché régi par
la concurrence est soumis à des frais y
prix fluctuants alors tout un système à
revoir on en parle dans cette deuxième
partie d'émission
qu'est ce que ce mr à 21h les toutes
premières discussions face à face entre
américains et talibans depuis le retrait
américain au coeur de cet échange au
qatar les questions sécuritaires et les
droits humains en particulier
l'intégration complets des femmes et des
filles dans la société afghane demain ce
sera au tour des responsables de l'ue
eux d'entamer des pourparlers alors les
fondamentalistes ont-ils vraiment bien
placé pour parler de ces problématiques
que faut-il attendre de ces discussions
décryptage dans une heure
[Musique]
une enseignante chahuté violemment par
l'un ses élèves dans un établissement de
combs-la-ville en seine-et-marne un
nouvel acte de violence filmées vendredi
dernier en plein cours et diffusés sur
les réseaux sociaux on en parle tout de
suite avec estelle farges devant le
lycée jacques prévert là où a eu lieu
cette agression bossoirs estelle trois
jours après cette scène de violence
l'éducation nationale se saisit de la
sphère
exactement et stéphanie la directrice
des services de l'éducation nationale de
seine et marne elle s'est rendue sur
place ici ce matin elle a rencontré
l'enseignante qui a été bousculée ainsi
que d'autres professeurs de
l'établissement une visite trois jours
après les faits donc qui se sont
déroulés ici sur lycée jacques prévert
pour rappel sur une vidéo diffusée sur
les réseaux sociaux on y voit une
enseignante être violemment bousculé en
plaques en plein cours par l'un de ses
élèves l'enseignante se tenait à devant
une porte face à un élève qui tentaient
de l'ouvrir l adolescent a attiré a
violemment sur la poignée ce qui a
projeté et bien l'enseignante au sol
l'élève a été exclut immédiatement à
titre conservatoire c'est en tout cas ce
qu'a indiqué lundi khademi de créteil
dont dépend ce lycée jacques prévert un
conseil de discipline va par la suite
être convoqué sachez aussi qu'une
cellule psychologique a été mise à
disposition des élèves et des
professeurs est elle désormais plusieurs
plaintes vont être déposées
mais exactement l'enseignante a déposé
plainte le parquet de melun confirme ce
soir qu'une enquête est ouverte pour
violences aux circonstances aggravantes
le proviseur du lycée devrait lui aussi
qui a déposé une plainte au nom de son
établissement non seulement contre
l'adolescent qui a violenté
l'enseignante mais aussi contre ceux qui
ont filmé et diffusé la scène sur les
réseaux sociaux de son côté l académie
de créteil a réaffirmé son soutien au
corps enseignant dans un communiqué elle
condamne les faits aucune menace ou
agressions qu'elles soient physiques ou
verbales à l'encontre des enseignants ne
peut être tolérée pour pouvait-on lire
dans ce communiqué merci et celles
chargées en direct de combs la ville en
seine et marne et une nouvelle agression
contre le corps enseignant qui suscite
de vives réactions notamment chez les
parents d'élèves de cet établissement on
écoute
étaient très choqués de voir ça je me
suis mise à la place de la professeure
je me suis dit que c'était pas cher payé
comme métier pour traverser ce genre de
choses au quotidien j'imagine en fait je
trouve ça vraiment honteux on s'attaque
à des à des professeurs surtout moi
j'étais dans ce lycée là avant et on n'a
jamais eu de problème
on n'a jamais on a géré le monde s'est
jamais attaqué à des professeurs on
était calmes
puis voilà quoi mais c'est vrai que
c'est vraiment quoi si l'élève a eu
cette réaction c'est qu'il ya vraiment
une il ya un problème et donc il a réagi
de cette manière là parce qu'en fait il
n'y avait pas de discussions et je pense
que c'est ça le problème dans ce lycée
là c'est qu'ils veulent pas discuter
avec les élèves mais un manque de
pédiatres beda pédagogie pardon il ya un
manque d'attention puisqu'ils sont dans
un lycée professionnel donc au fait ils
mettent tout le monde dans le même sac
et ça peut remonter même à l'académie
numéro au rectorat mais il n'écoute pas
et c'est ça le problème chez eux c'est
qu'ils écoutent pas les élèves et une
fois qu'ils ont ce genre de problème là
bas c'est là où ils veulent réagir mais
c'est trop tard cette nouvelle violence
en milieu scolaire relance le débat sur
la question de la sécurité des
enseignants sur leur lieu de travail une
nouvelle agression qui arrive alors que
la france s'apprête à rendre un hommage
à samuel pâtit il ya près d'un an ce
professeur d'histoire géo était décapité
par un jeune réfugié tchétchène vendredi
prochain plusieurs cérémonies sont
prévues dans tout le pays en particulier
dans les établissements scolaires mais
son organisation divise les parents
comme les élèves soleil web
une minute de silence suivie d'une heure
de discussion avec les élèves c'est
ainsi que ce vendredi le ministère de
l'éducation nationale prévoit de rendre
hommage à samuel pâti dans de nombreux
établissements scolaires le 16 octobre
dernier ce professeur d'histoire
géographie de 47 ans était décapité par
un jeune réfugié tchétchène dans une rue
voisine du collège du bois d'aulne à
conflans sainte honorine où il exerçait
les jours précédents samuel bhatti avait
été la cible de messages réclamant sa
démission sur les réseaux sociaux après
avoir montré des caricatures de mahomet
en classe
un assassinat qui avait déclenché une
onde de choc dans tout le pays un an
plus tard ce devoir de mémoire ravive
l'émotion chez les élèves parmi ceux de
samuel pâtit certains se sont confiés à
l'hebdomadaire le point ils disent
vouloir tourner la page j'ai envie
d'oublier j'essaie de commencer une
bonne année l'année dernière c'était pas
ouf ressasser le passé serait trop dur
pour moi j'essaie d'aller de l'avant en
oubliant cet événement de leur côté dans
une lettre ouverte au ministère de
l'éducation nationale des représentants
des parents d'élèves regrette d'être
écarté des commémorations prévues dans
les écoles la veille d'une cérémonie
plus intime avec la famille de samuel
paty et le président de la république
si vous ne changez pas d'avis concernant
l'hommage du 15 octobre nous les
représentants de parents d'élèves
n'assisterons pas à l'hommage officiel
du 16 octobre nous ne servirons pas de
caution soit vous considérez les parents
comme faisant partie intégrante de cet
établissement soit vous les en exclu et
un texte resté lettre morte comme deux
autres mesures réclamées par les
associations de parents d'élèves
rebaptisé le collège du bois d'aulne du
nom de samuel paty et lui ériger une
statue
face à ces revendications seul
l'académie de versailles envisage de
délocaliser la commémoration afin de
pouvoir accueillir plus de participants
dans le respect des règles sanitaires en
vigueur une proposition symbolique pour
les parents d'élèves qui craignent que
l'assassinât de samuel pâtit deviennent
d'une simple date de recueillement sans
mesures de fond liés à la liberté
d'expression et la laïcité le débat
divise donc un on l'aura compris chez
les professeurs les parents d'élèves et
les élèves eux mêmes alors faut-il
rendre hommage à samuel pâti dans ces
conditions dans les établissements
scolaires c'est l'objet de notre face à
face ce soir
[Musique]
et
avec nous pour en parler ce soir
jean-marc chipeau porte-parole de debout
la france en direct avec nous bonsoir
jean marc flipo merci d'être avec nous à
vos côtés sur ce plateau les ronds de
fontaine par parole de fabien roussel a
le candidat du parti communiste à
l'élection présidentielle bonsoir même
si d'être avec nous hommage donc un on
l'a dit prévu vendredi dans toutes les
écoles une minute de silence suivie d'un
temps de réflexion
il faut savoir que l'année dernière cet
hommage au professeur assassiné avait
été perturbée 793 fois selon un décompte
du ministère de l'éducation nationale
jean marc thibault est ce qu'on doit
craindre qu'il y ait la même chose cette
année un risque de perturbation l'ordre
lors de cet hommage en tout cas c'est ce
que vous craignez vous on peut le
redouter un de craindre le séparait du
que l'éducation nationale ne doit pas
craindre de rendre hommage à l'un des
siens qui est tombé en défendant les
valeurs fondamentales de la république
sont là la liberté de conscience la
liberté d'expression la tolérance donc
si on commence à craindre de rendre
hommage à des à des défenseurs de ces
valeurs là on a plus qu'à fermer tous
les établissements scolaires de france
non on peut le redouter en revanche et
malheureusement on prépare pas les
choses d'une bonne manière puisque dans
la manière dont c'est dans cette annonce
et le ministère de l'éducation nationale
parle d'un hommage qui peut aller
jusqu'à une heure c'est pas une heure
dommage c'est jusqu'à 1h dommage on
laisse les équipes décidées en fonction
je peux pas vous dire de bêtises en
fonction de leur situation respective
c'est à dire qu'on sait fille déjà de
l'unité de l'enseignement et de
l'éducation nationale on considère qu'il
ya des offres des établissements dans
lesquels on pourra pas faire on pourra
pas faire cet hommage et puis pardon
mais encore une fois quand drôle je vous
dois apprendre le texte de l'éducation
nationale qui parle d'une séquence
spécifique sur la construction esprit
critique ainsi que sur le métier de prof
son rôle sa légitimité c'est à dire que
dans l'énoncé même de l'hommage on va te
dire on va discuter de la légitimité des
professeurs mais pardon moi je peux pas
entendre ça je ne peux pas entendre
qu'un gouvernement met une heure des
changes pour que les élèves et les
professeurs discutent de la légitimité
de des professeurs de l'éducation
nationale on va passer la parole et les
deux fontaines mais tout d'abord je
voudrais vous rappeler à cette nouveauté
à partir de ce soir vous pouvez vous
réagir sur notre compte télégramme rt
france pour venir apporter un petit peu
voilà deux de l'eau au moulin de ce
débat donner votre sentiment vos
réactions léon de fontaine vous partager
la même je dirais indignation que
monsieur chipeau on a pas à discuter de
la légitimité du professeur pendant cet
hommage ça me chante également vous avez
tout à fait une autre approche moi je
pense que c'est cet hommage le meilleur
moyen de rendre hommage à samuel paty et
à la mission de l'enseignement c'est de
l'entretenir tout au long de l'année et
je pense qu'il faut pouvoir ouvrir des
discussions des échanges bien évidemment
tout au long de l'année avec les
enseignants sur ce que c'est que ce
métier ce beau métier que certains
appellent et que je appelle également le
plus beau métier du monde et pour cela
il faut pas les considérer que pendant
une heure il faut pas leur laisser la
place que pendant une heure et bien tout
au long de l'année et ça ça implique une
chose que le gouvernement n'a pas fait
c'est de pouvoir écouter aussi les
revendications qu'ils ont sur leurs
conditions de travail sur la
revalorisation de leur travail et je
pense que la priorité devrait être celle
ci et je pense que ce serait le meilleur
hommage justement à rendre à samuel
pâtit en tout cas vous avez été nombreux
déjà à réagir tout au long de la journée
un sur cette question qui est posée
faut-il rendre hommage à semelle pâti
dans ces conditions dans les
établissements scolaires on va voir une
de vos réponses débat ne fait
qu'alimenter la division au sens de la
population et pour qu'au final ce soit
ce gouvernement fantoche qui soit
gagnant est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec cette analyse
delà de nos téléspectateurs jean marc
flipo
va écouter de toute évidence ce débat va
être client mais maintenant on peut pas
je sais je suis pas suspect de de
défendre de défendre le gouvernement
bien sûr qu'il ya on a vu dans votre
reportage il ya déjà des clivages qui se
sont créés entre le gouvernement et les
parents d'élèves mais pour autant on
peut pas on peut pas renoncer à
honorer les ce qui constitue les valeurs
cardinales de notre république jean
michel blanquer a déclaré récemment que
l'assassinât de que le maire de saint
gall pâtit était un une insulte à la
démocratie c'est pas une insulte à la
démocratie c'est la démocratie qu'on
assassine
c'est la république qu'on assassine et
face à ça je suis désolé il faut faire
bloc et on va effectivement peut-être se
compter on va compter les gens qui font
bloc derrière les valeurs de la
république encore une fois des valeurs
de liberté de conscience de liberté
d'expression des valeurs de tolérance et
puis on va compter ceux qui sont pas
d'accord avec ça et ça c'est le vrai
problème qui va falloir régler
effectivement dans l'est dans les
semaines et mois les amitiés à léon de
fontaine il ya ce malaise justement dans
l'éducation nationale aujourd'hui à
parler de l'assassinât d'une victime à
son bon sens d'un enseignant au nom
d'une religion il faut prendre à bras le
corps ce problème aujourd'hui dans le
pays clairement bien sûr qu'il faut
prendre à bras le corps mais je réagis
aussi à l'intervention précédentes je
pense pas qu'il s'agit de laure de
sauteuses cet hommage de se compter il
s'agit surtout de regarder comment on
fait en effet l'unité comment on fait
bloc comment on arrive à rassembler
l'ensemble des acteurs de l'éducation
pour pouvoir justement rendre hommage
non seulement à samuel paty et faire
vivre sa mémoire en faisant vivre
l'éducation nationale comme institution
républicaine garante des libertés et moi
je pense que ce serait désastreux de
montrer du doigt justement celles et
ceux qui n'auraient pas été très propre
et dans 1 1 dans des agissements qui
aurait permis qui peuvent être montrés
du doigt le critiquer je pense qu'au
contraire il faut regarder comment
l'école l'éducation nationale est
inclusive et arrive à inclure l'ensemble
des citoyens parce que si on n'arrive
pas à faire ça et qu'on commence à créer
des divisions alors malheureusement
malheureusement je pense qu'on passera à
côté de cet hommage et surtout à côté de
ce que samuel patty a essayé de faire
tout au long de son travail tous
dénoncent justement dans la lignée de ce
que nous dit allez on de fontaines 1
voilà on venait de voir un tweet qui a
disparu mais j'ai essayé de le retrouver
effectivement si on peut me le remettre
à l'instant c'est pas grave enfin en
gros on parlait de voilà ne risque-t-on
pas de provoquer une nouvelle division
entre les pour et les contre et de
générer de la violence voire intime à de
guerre civile je rebondis aussi sur ce
que vous disiez tout à l'heure jean marc
flipo voilà il faut se compter il n'ya
pas toujours
cette espèce de climat très clivant qui
semble devenir un petit peu le la de
cette campagne présidentielle qui se
lance
du pardon mais quand on parle de
violence qu'est ce qu'il ya de plus
violent que la décapitation d'un
enseignant je voudrais qu'on m'explique
si ça c'est pas de l'ultra violence
alors ça veut dire qu'on en a perdu le
sens des mots ensuite il s'agit pas
s'agit pas de diviser je dis qu'on va
escompter parce que c'est ce qui se
passera dans les faits c'est bien
évidemment pas un sou s par un projet ça
peut pas en être le projet bien
évidemment ces deux de rétablir cette
république que l'on aime qui est une et
indivisible
dans tous ces territoires dans toutes
ses composantes
moi je remarque pour
être un peu plus léger peut-être je
remarque dans la vidéo on voit pas
toutes les vidéos sur l'agression de
l'enseignante de combs la ville moi je
vois marquant même que dans la vidéo
malgré le bazar ambiant lac avec des
élèves qui sont enlevés pour la
secourir pour la relever donc tout n'est
pas perdu il ya eu effectivement un
énorme un énorme travail à faire mais en
attendant il ya des choses qui sont
dites ligne rouge on ne peut pas
franchir or je suis désolé l'hommage à
sa belle patine en tout cas pour moi
c'est un marqueur fort le gouvernement
ne peut pas faire l'économie de cela et
je suis désolé des guildes manière ou
d'une autre il faut que ce message passe
dans la tête de tout un chacun et ceux
qui sont réfractaires à ce message s'est
dit quelque chose et il faudra il faudra
s'en occuper pardon mais si les faits
les faits sont têtus alors il ya
justement cet autre débat dans le débat
qui touche finalement seul le débat de
fond le pourquoi de l'assassinât d'un de
ces nouvelles patine il a trouvé la mort
nous dit sandrine c'est après avoir
voulu éveillé ses élèves sur la
tolérance et le droit au blasphème on en
revient à ce thème qui est assez
récurrent
vous avez la même analyse que cette
téléspectatrice qui qui vous écris ce
soir oui bien sûr mais je pense que
l'éducation à un rôle une mission c'est
pas uniquement former les travailleurs
de demain s'est formée et à former les
citoyens de demain permettre
l'épanouissement et la libération la du
carcan religieux familiale philosophique
continue à nous inculquer à nos parents
et ouvrir aussi les esprits et je pense
que c'est un des rôles fondamental de
l'éducation nationale malheureusement
avec les moyens qu'elle a actuellement
on a tendance à déléguer sa roue médecin
au second plan or je pense qu'il faut
justement réfléchir peut être repenser
les missions de l'éducation nationale
pour justement revenir aux fondamentaux
et notamment permettre à chaque élève et
à chaque enseignant de pouvoir éduquer
former les élèves les instruire dans les
meilleures conditions possibles et pour
cela il faut qu on pose les vrais sujets
aujourd'hui il ya trop d effectifs par
classe le métier d'enseignement et
malheureusement dévaloriser notamment au
niveau du salaire et je pense qu'il
faudrait 1 2 meyer zonage compris en
assam elle pâtit c'est justement de
revaloriser ce plus beau ce beau métier
d'enseignant et ça ça implique de
dédoubler les classes de redonner du
sens en dédoublant les classes pas plus
de 25 élèves par classe ne recruter des
enseignants partout sur le territoire
pour offrir la meilleure instruction à
nos jeunes aux nouvelles générations aux
enfants ça passe également par augmenter
le temps à l'école aussi pour permettre
justement de répondre à toutes ses
missions et nous c'est bien l'ambition
que nous portons avec la condition aussi
de fano là vous êtes allés au delà
effectivement de ce débat en parler
aussi du droit au blasphème puisque
c'est aussi l'un des aspects de ce débat
je voudrais à ce propos justement vous
montrer une étude ifop réalisée au
printemps dernier sur la place de la
religion pour les lycéens et bien
regardez 52 % des lycéens conteste la
liberté de se montrer irrespectueux
vis-à-vis d'une religion et de ses
dogmes le droit au blasphème est donc
clairement contestée par les lycéens
français jean marc flipo ça vous inspire
quoi
hans devient comme aux états unis
justement il est ça peut vous étonner de
la part des jeunes justement ce
sentiment
ça m'étonne de la moyennement de la part
du jeune puisque c'est on voit bien
qu'il ya une vague de plus en plus
importante justement de là comment dire
de prosélytisme de prosélytisme
religieux pendant qu'on avant en en
abandonner certaines certaines valeurs
chrétiennes et à l'islam qui étaient
venus s'imposer avec tout son corps tout
cela l'islam c'est un projet blue qui
concerne tous les jeunes allaient même
gêne d'ailleurs peut-être on dit souvent
on rappelle qui dans les sondages
peut-être s'intéresse à eric zemmour et
marine le pen oui tout à fait bien fait
je vous donnais
49 % des enseignants en suite à
l'assassinât sa belle bâtisse
inquiétudes qui était établie en
décembre 2020 49 % des enseignants
déclarait on s'auto censurer et ne pas
dans leur enseignement de comment dire
de des programmes d prenant religieux
donc déjà a déjà avec des enseignants
eux-mêmes s'autocensurent il faut pas
s'étonner que derrière avec la pression
globale qu'on assure sur justement le
fait religieux maintenant en france faut
pas s'étonner qu'on arrive à des à des
chiffres pareils au sein des lycéens
maintenant il ya effectivement
l'éducation doit doit pouvoir remplir
son rôle pour qu'elle puisse remplir son
rôle il ya un préalable qui est
incontournable c'est d'assurer la
sécurité des enseignants et d'assurer le
calme dans les classes or à l'heure
actuelle si vous voyez là l'intégralité
de la vidéo de combs-la-ville justement
vous voyez qu avant même l'incident
c'est ainsi tout sauf le calme dans la
classe moi j'entendais 7 cette personne
qui disait qu'il y avait pas d' on
n'écoutait pas les élèves
mais c'est complètement délirant
regardez cette vidéo et vous verrez le
bazar intégral qu'il ya dans cette place
c'est pas de la faute de l'enseignant
c'est le quotidien des enseignants à dix
au bout la france en a beaucoup
d'enseignants qui nous remontent qui
nous font tous remonter les mêmes
informations ce qui s'est passé à
combs-la-ville c'est pas quelque chose
d' isoler c'est le quotidien des
enseignants et danses et des enseignants
qui sont livrés à eux mêmes qu'ils ne
sont pas soutenus par leur hiérarchie à
chaque fois qu'ils veulent dénoncer des
faits de
l'agressivité on leur dit non quand vous
êtes vous êtes dans l'excès rêve où vous
avez mal interprété telle ou telle chose
et à tel point qu'en 2018 il y avait un
autre on va dire un autre incident qui
était encore plus grave qui s'était
déroulé à créteil où un élève avait
braqué un pistolet sur la tête de l'un
de ses professeurs
heureusement pistolet factice mais ça
avait donné lieu à l'époque à au hashtag
pas de vagues les enseignants avaient
mis en ligne sur twitter le hashtag pas
de vagues parce qu'il se sentait
totalement abandonné 2 lors de leur
hiérarchie et il pouvait pas remonter
les informations et déjà à l'époque en
2018 on avait des grands coups de menton
tantôt de jean michel blanquer en tout
cas
gabriella talent tu disais comment on va
on va remettre la sécurité dans les
classes vous allez voir on va la
primauté de respect des professeurs on
est trois ans trois années plus tard et
apparemment il s'est produit à l'est en
de fontaine alors justement quand on
entend cette maman dire oui en gros en
substance un jeu je résume effectivement
c'est la faute des professeurs il n'y a
pas d' écoute ça vous choque vous dites
il ya un manque maintenant de respect
delà de la fonction peut-être
de professeurs et que les voilà c'était
un discours qui peut vous vous choquer a
laissé un discours qui est qui est
choquant à quoi je pense que le problème
ne vient pas de l'éducation nationale en
tant que tel mais du ministère de
l'éducation nationale aussi qui a sa
part de responsabilité parce qu'en fait
cela fait maintenant un certain nombre
d'années qu'on entend ce discours sur
les enseignants sur les profs sur le
fait qu' il serait trop payés qu'eux ils
ne travaillent pas assez suffisamment 30
on l'a entendu mais de moins en moins et
fort heureusement quand on voit le
salaire d'un enseignant quand il
commence en carrière et même à la fin de
sa carrière mais en fait derrière le
salaire et la valeur comporte
aujourd'hui aux métiers sont deux choses
qui sont liés or le gel du point
d'indicé
cela fait maintenant de nombreuses
années qu'on demande à ce qu'il soit
levé et que les fonctionnaires est un
salaire qu'ils soient plus élevés nous
propose l'augmentation de 30% des
salaires mais on propose aussi de
redonner du sens à ce boulot parce
qu'aujourd'hui malheureusement il ya
aussi une perte de sens pour toute la
société de ce que c'est que ce boulot et
donc pour cela il faut offrir des
meilleures conditions de travail qui
offriront des meilleures conditions
d'études et c'est ça qui permettront de
revaloriser ce métier pas uniquement
auprès des lycéens des collégiens ou des
de l'ensemble de la jeunesse mais bien
dans l'ensemble de la société et moi je
pense que c'est important essentiel et
bien évidemment il faut avoir un
ministère qui puisse soutenir l'ensemble
de son équipe pédagogique l'ensemble des
enseignants est aujourd'hui
malheureusement force est de constater
que ce n'est pas le cas parce qu'ils les
méprise lorsqu'ils sortent dans la rue
lorsqu'ils manifestent lorsqu'ils
revendiquent ils les méprisent il refuse
de les écouter écoutons ce qu'on a à
dire ces enseignants et regardons avec
eux construisons avec eux un projet
politique global pour l'éducation
nationale qui permettent d'offrir non
seulement les meilleures conditions de
travail et surtout la meilleure
instruction pour la jeunesse merci
beaucoup
léon de fontaine jean marc flipo d'avoir
été avec nous devra accepter ce face à
face et merci à vous pour toutes vos
réactions sur télégramme rt france vous
pourrez le faire évidemment tous les
soirs à l'occasion de nos face-à-face
quotidien merci
la vaccination contre le kobe 19 en
france serait bel et bien efficace selon
deux rapports publiés aujourd'hui par un
groupement d'intérêt scientifique
une étude menée sur 22 millions de
personnes premier constat la vaccination
contre le coc vide avec les principaux
sérum utilisé en france réduit de 90%
risque d'hospitalisations et de décès
chez les plus de 50 ans deuxième constat
tombe aussi efficace face aux variants
delta sur lequel on manque toutefois
encore de recul et pendant ce temps les
taux force est de constater se resserre
sur les non vaccinés à partir de
vendredi des tests pcr et antigénique ne
seront plus remboursés par la sécurité
sociale sauf rares exceptions et
précision de l'udc allégé
depuis le 12 juillet dernier et les
annonces des manuels macron sur le pass
sanitaires l'exécutif n'a pas bougé d'un
iota dans son jusqu'au boutisme
vaccinale est désormais si vous avez
exercer votre droit à ne pas vous faire
vacciner contre le coc vite 19 votre vie
va devenir encore plus dur comme promis
comme annoncé par le président de la
république le 12 juillet dernier la fin
de la gratuité générale des tests de
dépistage du coc vite 19 sera mise en
oeuvre le 15 octobre 2021
le gouvernement continue ainsi à
encourager la vaccination qui constitue
la meilleure façon de se protéger et de
protéger les autres est la clef de la
sortie durable de crise fini donc les
tests dits de confort qui permettait à
ceux qui refusent le vaccin d'avoir une
vie à peu près normale entre deux tests
naso pharyngé remboursés par la sécurité
sociale désormais il faudra payer il est
arriv sont dissuasifs environ 22 à 45
euros en france métropolitaine en
fonction du moyen utilisé n'espérait pas
non plus vous en tirez avec un autotest
qui coûte environ 5 euros ils ne
permettent plus d'obtenir le qr code qui
ouvre toutes les portes il y a quand
même des exceptions détaillé par le
ministère de la santé notamment pour les
mineurs ou les personnes ciné les autres
devront avoir une prescription médicale
pour bénéficier d'un test rembourser ils
ont réussi leurs objectifs mais encore
une fois on voit bien que voilà
l'objectif du pass à une terre c'est pas
un objectif sanitaire c'est un objectif
politique l'objectif politique c'est
quoi c'est de vacciner tout le monde
même si on voit de plus en plus dans les
études notamment américaines que la
vaccination ne protège pas aussi bien
contre la transmissibilité du virus donc
c'est toujours la même chose donc oui le
gouvernement a gagné son pari si vous
voulez mais ce qui serait bien c'est pas
que le gouvernement gagne c'est que la
raison triomphe un peu comme maintenant
qu'on a accepté le principe du passé à
lithaire et d'accepter de vivre comme
société contrôle
on vous a restreint l'accès au bar et au
restaurant
qu'est-ce qui peut demain empêcher je ne
sais pas moi les banques de vous refuser
une ouverture de compte si vous n'êtes
pas vacciné
qu'est-ce qui peut rhdp qu'est ce qui
peut empêcher demain qu'on étende à à
d'autres secteurs
je moi je pense qu'on n'a pas fini d'en
voir le bout et c'est vrai que c'est
très inquiétant parce que les gens se
sont accoutumés à ça ils se sont
accoutumés à montrer un qr code très
naturellement très simplement mais ils
ne comprennent pas de basculement
anthropologique philosophique et
politique dans lequel nous sommes depuis
quelques mois maintenant selon le
ministère de la santé la vaccination est
le seul moyen de sortir de la crise et
il reste 7 5 millions de personnes
éligibles à vacciner tous les moyens
sont bons pour aller les chercher y
compris les plus contraignants certains
dans la classe politique veulent aller
plus loin le 13 octobre les sénateurs
débattront d'une proposition de loi
socialiste visant à ajouter le coït 19
au vaccin obligatoire une proposition de
loi qui a cependant peu de chances
d'aboutir puisque la commission des
affaires sociales du sénat a d'ores et
déjà rejeté le texte ce qui laisse
penser que la majorité n'est pas
favorable à la mesure du moins pour
l'instant
comment expliquer la faillite
énergétique de l'union européenne une
question au centre d'une enquête de
mediapart après la hausse des prix du
gaz et d'électricité en europe ce
rapport met en cause la décision
bruxelles de traiter le marché de
l'électricité comme un marché régi par
la concurrence est soumis à des prix
fluctuants l'europe doit annoncer dans
deux jours de meuse des mesures
temporaires mais sur le long terme le
problème semble plus difficile les
précisions de sébastien abba
l'europe de l'énergie devaient à
l'origine faire baisser les prix du gaz
et de l'électricité
pourtant en près de 20 ans les prix ont
augmenté de 70% en france en cause la
décision de bruxelles de traiter le
marché de l'électricité comme un marché
régi par la concurrence est soumis à des
prix fluctuants le ministre français de
l'économie a fustigé ce système le
marché unique européen de l'électricité
ne marche pas il est aberrant il faut
revoir de fond en comble le
fonctionnement du marché unique de
l'électricité les français on paie la
facture d'une manière incompréhensible
pour eux est totalement inefficace du
point de vue économique
cette création d'un marché unique de
l'énergie mais tous les pays de l'union
à genoux en france malgré une levée de
boucliers suivi du gel temporaire des
tarifs jusqu'en avril prochain le
problème n'est pas réglé un répit
pourrait cependant s'offrir aux
consommateurs français la commission
européenne va inciter les états membres
à baisser leurs taxes sur l'énergie
la totalité des états vont bénéficier de
cette situation parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de taxes sur l'énergie inciter à baisser
ses taxes pour redistribuer aux plus
défavorisés
la situation force le gouvernement
français à revoir sa stratégie
énergétique
emmanuel macron doit annoncer demain les
détails de son plan d'investissement
france 2030 qui comprendra notamment le
développement de petits réacteurs
nucléaires
pour rappel le président sortant avait
promis lors de sa campagne de 2010 est
une baisse de 50% de la part du
nucléaire en france à l'horizon 2025
et justement ce plan d'investissement
france 2030 d' emmanuel macron devrait
faire la part belle aux réacteurs
nucléaires innovant de quoi s'agit-il
pourquoi le choix de cette technologie
pour la france fait il déballe essentiel
en images
[Musique]
elle
oh
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir claude
blanchemaison merci d'être avec nous
comment expliquer ces hôtes s'est auto
au spla grande de l'électricité alors
pour certains on l'a vu c'est
directement lié à la façon dont a été
conçue marché européen de l'énergie est
ce qu'ils disent vrai
d'abord c'est un phénomène général c'est
à dire que partout dans le monde les néo
le prix l'énergie augmentent pour une
raison très simple c'est que il y à une
reprise économique heureusement après la
période de repli duo pourrait vite dû à
la pandémie ensuite parce que
effectivement je crois qu'on peut dire
que il n'y a pas de marché de
l'électricité il n'y a pas de marché
unique monsieur le maire aurait pu aller
jusqu'au bout de sa pensée en disant
cela car chaque état membre a voulu
retenir deux choses d'abord sa liberté
de choisir son mixte économique comment
je fabrique mon électricité nucléaire ou
pas nucléaire charbon pas charbon
pétrole ou pas pétrole gaz et puis les
énergies renouvelables à quel rythme et
ce que je les ai introduit dans mon
cocktail pour fabriquer l'énergie
nucléaire et chaque état reste libre
parce que c'est un choix très politique
et par conséquent aucun état ne veut
délégué ce choix à bruxelles
probablement d'ailleurs à juste titre
deuxièmement également n'y a pas de
marché parce que il n'ya pas
interconnexion des réseaux il ya une
directive une vieille directive
européenne qui dit qu interconnexion
devrait être au niveau de 20% entre la
production de chaque état membre on en
est bien loin et avec l'espagne par
exemple elle est environ de 4 à 5% donc
il n'y a pas possibilité
électricité circule très mal on ne sait
pas stocker l'électricité on sait
stocker l'énergie primaire qui sert à la
fabrique et on ne peut pas stocker en
effet par ailleurs il ya aussi des
acteurs privés les grandes compagnies
pétrolières ou gazières qui considèrent
que leur aire de jeu n'est pas l'europe
n'est pas à l'état membre c'est le monde
donc prise entre le marché mondial et
les états membres qui gardent beaucoup
de compétences en effet l'union
européenne est un petit peu en
lévitation et par conséquent essais
d'édicter des règles pour l'avenir pour
respecter des objectifs qui sont des
objectifs écologiques pour lutter contre
le réchauffement climatique mais qui
sont finalement assez marginaux par
rapport à la politique de fabrication de
l'électricité est à son prix qui en
effet est différent d'un pays à l'autre
d'ailleurs en france il est inférieur à
la moyenne de ce qu'il est dans les pays
de l'union européenne en allemagne c'est
beaucoup plus élevés et au danemark
s'est également beaucoup plus élevé
alors l'ouverture du marché de
l'électricité à la concurrence a été
qualifié par une association de
consommateurs on l'a vu dans dans le
sujet 1 comme un échec je cite qui
s'avère nuisible pour le bien-être des
consommateurs
en quoi il est il oui en effet on peut
regretter la belle époque où edf
electricité de france gaz de france
était de monopole que les français mais
bien d'ailleurs est en effet certains
partis politiques regrettent cette
période il se trouve que le choix qui a
été fait est différent en effet sous la
pression de bruxelles le législateur le
parlement a décidé en 2000 de supprimer
le monopole de edf et en 2006 de
privatiser gaz de france et donc par
conséquent d'autres acteurs
interviennent sur le marché et
je crois que à juste titre on remarque
en effet que les prix ont continué
d'augmenter peut-être même plus
rapidement qu'avant parce qu'il faut
entretenir le réseau parce qu'il ya des
frais de transport qui sont importants
parce qu'il faut s'ajuster à la demande
et par conséquent la concurrence n'a pas
apporté une baisse des prix sur le
marché français pas plus que sur les
marchés voisins dans les autres pays
d'europe où ils ont également beaucoup
augmenté alors le nucléaire qui semble
revenir en grâce et en le voit ici ou là
même dans la bouche de certains verts
face à cette hausse fulgurante des prix
qu'on dit aucune branche maison cette
crise de l'avenir du nucléaire en europe
subit indique on est à un moment de
vérité parce que en effet si l'on veut
respecter les objectifs écologiques la
commission voudrait que l'union
européenne soit neutre sur le plan
carbone en 2050 2050 c'est après demain
la coop 26 qui va se réunir au début du
mois prochain à glasgow
n'aboutira pas à un résultat de ce genre
parce que des pays comme la chine l'inde
les états unis s'y opposeront ces trois
pays consomme 60 % de la production de
charbon du monde par conséquent ils sont
pas du tout prêts à renoncer au charbon
et arriver à un objectif qui soit neutre
en carbone aussi rapidement ou s'ils
prennent un engagement ce ne sera pas
très sérieux car il sera pas suivie
d'effet alors en effet l'une des façons
les plus évidentes d'aller vers cet
objectif de neutralité carbone c'est de
recourir au nucléaire là dessus il y ait
un désaccord entre les états membres de
l'union européenne y est aussi un
désaccord entre les partis politiques
les verts les écologistes sont hostiles
à l'énergie nucléaire et prenons les
devants dans le fond madame merkel a
organisé la sortie de l'allemagne du
nucléaire et par conséquent est bien le
recours accru
au charbon pendant une période
transitoire et au gaz d'où l'importance
que nord stream 2 pour la transition
énergétique en allemagne je note
d'ailleurs que le représentant permanent
de la russie à bruxelles a fait des
déclarations à la presse ce matin en
disant qu' il avait de bonnes raisons de
croire que le kremlin avait recommandé à
gazprom d'augmenter ses livraisons de
gaz et s'il le dit c'est qu'il a
instructions de le dire par conséquent
je pense que la russie va faire un geste
pour leur le fond faciliter la
résolution de ce problème aussi parce
que c'est l'intérêt de personne que les
états membres retourne au charbon
évidemment pour nous nous avons 70 %
notre d'autres électricité qui est
produit par les 56 réacteurs nucléaires
et en effet je pense que on frappe de
nouveaux réacteurs reclesne nucléaire
peut être pas uniquement les opère peut
être des petits réacteurs plus adapté à
la situation plus souple est également
plus facile à exporter merci beaucoup
claude blanche les enfants cet éclairage
et la question environnementale toujours
avec un projet de retenue d'eau qui
divise en haute savoie la raison cet
ouvrage doit être construit en plein
coeur d'une zone protégée les
associations environnementales ont donc
décidé de faire barrage contre ce projet
qui selon elle serait dangereux pour
l'écosystème et détails avec juliette
lamy et jordi demory des paysages à
couper le souffle une faune et une flore
exceptionnelles le domaine de la clusaz
en haute-savoie après ce que quelque
chose de féerique situé à 1500 mètres
d'altitude
cette tourbière de 9 hectares est classé
et protégé par le réseau natura 2000 un
lieu jusqu'à présent peu connu mais qui
pourrait bien connaître un certain
nombre de changements car le projet
d'une réserve de 148 mille mètres cubes
d'eau devrait voir le jour au coeur de
cette zone naturelle un chantier de plus
de 10 millions d'euros dont l'objectif
est simple assurer une alimentation en
eau potable et surtout une production de
neige artificielle mais d'après
plusieurs associations environnementales
ce programme pourrait totalement
dénaturé le pays âge et avoir de lourdes
conséquences sur l'écosystème dans les
annales bois de la colombière du
derrière ce bois va être
saccagé détruit en grande partie si on
est sur un espace très protégé on a un
espace vierge sans construction sans
qu'on appelle lits touristiques
très peu de restaurants avec des zones
de sa gamme deux arrêtés préfectoraux
pour de protection d'espèces animales et
végétales
les gens aujourd'hui même en valais ne
veulent pas qu'on porte atteinte à ce
paysage encore très bien
pour tenter de faire bouger les choses
les associations ont décidé d'envoyer ce
lundi une lettre adressée à emmanuel
macron une manière de le sensibiliser à
ce combat écologique une enquête
publique a également été menée clôturée
le 20 septembre dernier elle compte plus
de 1800 observation
les résultats montrent que 75% des
sondés dénoncent le projet mais dans
plusieurs médias le maire de la ville a
réfuté cette enquête estimant que la
plupart des avis proviennent de
personnes extérieures à la clusaz et que
la majorité des locaux soutiennent le
projet qui on pouvait avoir le plus
longtemps possible de la neige ce serait
plus intéressant pour notre village
c'est certes pour nos dépit notre
clientèle qui viennent tous les
week-ends ce qui y est j'ai positif on
c'est à dire de vos plus de monde au
moins ressort des jeunes il nous faut de
la neige pour faire la neige une photo
pour les touristes il faut de l'eau
aussi faut bien qu'ils cela il qu'ils
boivent et qui on en a besoin voilà
alors sur le développement de la station
il le faut si la mairie assure que la
ville manque cruellement d'eau potable
les associations elles en sont persuadés
ce projet va surtout servir à développer
le tourisme autour du ski contacté par
la rédaction de rtl france à plusieurs
reprises la mairie de la clusaz n'a pas
donné suite à nos demandes d'interview
un nouvelle brouille entre paris et
londres sur la gestion migratoire ces
trois derniers jours plus de 1400
migrants ont été secourus dans la manche
alors qu'il tentait de rejoindre les
côtes britanniques
un influent à l'origine des frictions et
qui pourrait trouver une issue
prochainement londres vient d'ailleurs
de confirmer sa participation financière
pour aider paris a géré le dossier
éminemment d'aïda
certaines tensions apaisées entre le
royaume uni et la france le secrétaire
d'état britannique en charge de
l'intérieur a assuré que la somme de 63
millions d'euros promise pour lutter
contre le trafic de migrants depuis des
côtes françaises seraient versés à paris
dans les prochaines semaines il s'agit
d'un processus administratif visant à
déterminer les flux financiers exact
comment cela se passe et quand
exactement
nous travaillons en étroite
collaboration avec les français et je
m'attends à ce que la question que vous
avez posé trouve sa réponse dans les
prochaines semaines une déclaration qui
intervient deux jours après leur appel
lancé par le ministre français de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin au
gouvernement britannique sur l'agglo
britannique n'a pas payé pour l'instant
ce qui nous a promis donc pour l'instant
il n'y a pas un euro qui a été versée
par le gouvernement britannique suite à
l'accord que voilà plusieurs mois j'ai
négocié avec ma mère et elle vu les
anglais sont des gens aux donneurs et je
suis certain que c'est un léger retard
de comptabilité et qu'ils tiendront
cette promesse nous aimons ça fait plus
de vingt ans que la france tient la
frontière pour nos amis britanniques de
son côté damien ninth n'a pas manqué de
préciser que la france devait redoubler
d'efforts dans sa gestion des migrants à
la frontière j'aimerais voir une
activité plus élevé d expulsion plus
nombreuses la france est un pays sûr si
on cherche à obtenir l'asile on doit le
demander dans les premiers pays sûr que
l'on atteint bien que cette
interprétation du droit d'asile soit
loin de faire l'unanimité
ce samedi
491 personnes dont des enfants ont été
arrêtés par la police britannique sur
une plage de la côte sud de l'angleterre
après une période traversée depuis la
france
et après avoir tancé londres ce week-end
sur la question migratoire gérald
darmanin salut la manière dont athènes
contrôler ses frontières le locataire de
la place beauvau est en déplacement en
grèce en ce début de semaine l'occasion
pour lui d'apppeler les autres pays du
sud de l'europe à reproduire je cite le
modèle grec un système mettant en place
des camps d'enregistrement sécurisés
comme celui inauguré récemment sur l'île
de samos en mer egée ainsi de fermer un
accès contrôlé inauguré fin septembre
entouré de barbelés et de miradors
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis liverpool au royaume uni avec
francesco rizzuto doyen de la faculté de
droit de l'université liverpool europe
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir francesco rizzotto merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france le
gouvernement britannique qui affirme
donc un qu'il donnerait à la france dans
les prochaines semaines l'argent le
fameux argent promis pour lutter contre
le trafic de migrants depuis les côtes
françaises 1,60 2.7 millions d'euros sur
deux ans
insuffisant nous le problème et est
finalement ailleurs et pas forcément que
financier
bonsoir
je
[Musique]
pense qu'ils auraient vidé un élan comme
lui qui dans cette affaire
pourquoi y aurait-il besoin de plusieurs
semaines pour soutenir les français
dans la lutte dans la reprise de
contrôle des frontières britanniques ce
qui était le sujet du brésil
a lui fait aucun doute il ya 1 ou même
de contrôle des frontières que tu es tu
lorsque le royaume uni faisait partie de
l'union européenne à des traités est en
place pour gérer le problème avec le prg
exciter les règles de l'union ne
s'applique plus match manche de wii
party où ça joue bien davantage que plus
qu'une politique de un sentiment de
et sciences
d'affaires de financement de 60
quelques millions d'euros c'est un
symptôme d'une crise profonde entre les
deux pays ça veut dire enrôle le royaume
uni ne doit-il pas prendre sa part
également parce que c'est vrai que ce
côté on donne de l'argent vous vous
débrouillez c'est un peu étrange n'est
ce pas
c'est étrange de ne pas laisser la a
fonctionné dans le passé je ne sais pas
si cela va continuer à fonctionner à
l'avenir je ne sais pas si c'est
millions d'euros sur il suffisant
pourquoi serait ce à la france de garder
nos frontières
quoi les français vont-ils s'en charger
c'est une véritable question
au vu du comportement du royaume uni
encore la france s'agissant des droits
de pêche comme l'archipel anglo normand
au vu des relations générales entre le
royaume uni et la france en vue du
comportement britanniques vis-à-vis
d'autres aspects des accords post
président pourquoi la france
devrait-elle se charger de cette
question en tout cas la france qui
réclame un traité avec ses voisins
britanniques sur ces questions
migratoires est ce qu'on peut espérer
des avancées raisonnable
a expliqué archos cela dès maintenant
ne serait pas si difficile de signer un
traité mais cela dépend du
le traité en substance dit que les
français doivent arrêter les migrants
les empêcher
de passer en angleterre comme cela
existait auparavant cela pourrait
fonctionner mais le texte lui-même a
changé de
vérité milk veut pouvoir refouler tous
ceux qui réussissent à traverser la
manche qui réussit à traverser la
protection frontalière que la france
offrir et au royaume uni pour moi cela
va à l'encontre du droit international
et je comprends que les français ne
soient pas d'accord le royaume uni doit
comprendre
qu'il doit négocier cultures traitées
plus ou moins comme celui de dublin avec
la france avec le reste de l'union
européenne afin de gérer le sujet avant
qu'il arrive
dans la manche je ne sais pas si le pour
blanc s'il ya la volonté de le faire
sous le gouvernement
actuel est en tout cas sous stricte yves
chatel la ministre de l'intérieur
britannique un plus de 1400 ans migrants
secourues au total c'est le bilan tu
sais ces trois derniers jours dans la
manche francesco risotto que dit ce
chiffre selon vous
non
je pense que l'idée pourrait nous sauver
des gens en danger va une fois de plus à
l'encontre du droit international c'est
tout simplement inacceptable
mais un sou prix tipa tel est le
ministère de l'intérieur c'est le type
de politique tel que essaye de vendre le
gouvernement britannique
et cela n'a rien de raisonnable
qui laisserait des gens se noyer
lorsqu'ils sont en danger dans la mer
une dizaine de ces gens font la
traversée en canot pneumatique
ils ne sont pas bien organisé notre
gouvernement le gouvernement britannique
pourquoi arrêter de faire de la
politique avec un sujet trop fondement
sérieux très difficile alors le ministre
de l'intérieur français a entendu gérald
darmanin qui prônent aujourd'hui le
modèle grec a le contrôle des frontières
il souhaite que les mets aux pays du sud
de l'europe puisse mettre en place des
camps d'enregistrement sécurisé comme
celui de ses mots pour vous c'est la
bonne solution
et des
jeux ne pense pas qu'il s'agit d'une
solution
où était la france autour des cinq ou
six dernières années
personnellement je connais l'italie et
je ne pense pas que construire des
histoires de concentration dans des pays
comme à lille il ailleurs en europe et
pour protéger nos frontières pour gérer
le problème politique serait une bonne
solution
[Musique]
banier bien sûr gérald darmanin a des
ambitions politiques par exemple
entre michel barnier mais je ne pense
pas que cela va résoudre le problème la
misère humaine ne disparaîtra pas mais
ça n'ira pas nous le resterons pas à
garder la conscience claire si nous
déléguons les problèmes à quelqu'un
d'autre je pense que cela va plus
profondément et je n'y pense pas que de
créer des camps est une bonne idée
rappelez-vous des camps au liban
qui était censée permettre et de gérer
la fille de nos grands
c'est un problème un peu différent bien
sûr par exemple comme le problème
israélo-palestinien et le sommet je ne
pense pas que construire de tels d'un
centre est une bonne solution
du coup comme en matière politique ça
peut être facile mais la facilité
politique n'est pas forcément la
solution dans ce qu'il s'agit de
résoudre des problèmes profonds région
surtout lorsqu'il s'agit de les déléguer
dans d'autres régions du monde où nous
n'avons pas la main merci vous
comprendrez scories d'auto rappel vous
êtes doyen de l'université devant le
royaume-uni merci d'avoir été avec nous
et dans le reste de l'actualité
internationale la politique en tunisie
en semaine après le limogeage du dernier
cabinet le pays s'est doté aujourd'hui
d'un nouveau gouvernement et pour la
première fois dans l'histoire de la
tunisie le chef de l'exécutif est une
femme un as de la bouden mais
l'universitaire de 63 ans et son équipe
restent très limitées dans leur mission
les prérogatives ont été
considérablement réduites après la
suspension du parlement par le président
kaïs saïd et précision de notre
correspondant à tunis ben chez be
il aura fallu attendre 11 semaines
pouvoir enfin un nouveau gouvernement en
tunisie après l'éviction de l'ancien
cabinet dit chen li shishi le 25 juillet
dernier depuis le palais de carthage le
président de la république s'est exprimé
en direct à la télé un discours qui a
clôturé cette cérémonie de nomination du
nouveau gouvernement de najlae bouden la
chef du gouvernement a affirmé que la
lutte contre la corruption sera le plus
importante objectifs de son gouvernement
qui compte aujourd'hui 26 membres avec
najda bouden 16 hommes neuf femmes samir
saïd un banquier a été nommé ministre de
l'économie tandis que l'avocat taoufik
chirac fit in hérite du portefeuille de
l'intérieur dont il a déjà été titulaire
entre septembre 2001 et janvier 2021
après un bref discours devant sa
nouvelle équipe et devant le président
de la république nadja bouden a laissé
place à la série mais le serment des
nouveaux ministres qui se sont présentés
devant le président une main sur le
coran afin de gérer servir le pays et la
constitution s'en est suivi un discours
d'une trentaine de minutes oukaïd sayyed
est revenu sur les raisons de son coup
de force et la nomination de ce nouveau
gouvernement
il a déclaré que c'était un jour
historique avant de remercier najda
bouden d'avoir accepté cette lourde
responsabilité en cette période de crise
il a enchaîné en disant que c'est un
honneur qu'une femme najlae bout d'aile
sur la première femme à la tête d'un
gouvernement tunisien et arabe un
message pour les femmes tunisiennes qui
doivent demeurer est toujours active
selon les mots du président le président
qui a ajouté qu'il compte bien sauver le
pays contre ce détracteur en tunisie
comme à l'étranger et ouvrir tous les
dossiers car il n'y a pas de place pour
ceux qui veulent porter atteinte à
l'état face aux nombreuses critiques
qu'il a essuyées ces derniers mois il a
déclaré qu'il ne marchait pas dans le
groupe car et qu'il était dans une
bataille de libération de son pays et
qu'il gagnera avec l'aide de dieu il a
eu un mot pour la justice en déclarant
qu'elle sera purifié et que les dossiers
et affaires liées à la corruption ou
devront être vite bouclée c'était un cas
il s'agit serein et déterminé qui s'est
présenté devant ses nouveaux ministres
un gouvernement en fin annoncée après
deux mois d'attenté de silence un
premier pas peut être pour sertir de
cette crise tant espéré par les
tunisiens restez avec nous dans quelques
instants nous parlerons des discussions
entre américains et talibans et se sont
posés autour d'une même table ce
week-end au 14 une première rencontre en
face à face depuis que les
fondamentalistes ont repris le pouvoir
en afghanistan il ya deux mois rester
avec
[Musique]
certains font entendre leur voix pour
les autres c'est le silence qui parle
[Musique]
ce sommet afrique france il va se
dérouler à à montpellier en l'absence
quand même des chefs d'état c'est une
première esquisse vous le trouvez quand
même ambitieux emmanuel macron le
président il a toujours voulu créer
cette connexion directe entre lui et le
terrain avec les différents acteurs
c'est vraiment une approche complètement
nouvelle est ce que c'est une bonne idée
aujourd'hui le sujet de l'afrique il est
tellement complexe est tellement grand
en termes de défis que personne ne peut
le résoudre tout seul parce qu'elle pose
d'amertume quand même vis-à-vis des
initiatives qui ont été menés par
emmanuel macron aucune je pense qu'on a
été en reste pas naïfs c'est avec on va
changer soixante ans d'histoire en deux
jours la france a compris quand même
qu'aujourd'hui il faut repenser les
relations
ça il faut pas être einstein pour
comprendre chance ou l'a compris non
c'est le comment on dit je crève du
changement c'est pas de de lutter contre
le passé mais ses deux pieds de mettre
toutes ses énergies dans la construction
du futur et c'est ce à quoi je vois je
m'attèle
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
était formé de gens merveilleux et de
aidé de jean ignoble en fait vous ne
savez pas comment votre fils est mort
vous devez enquêter sur tout et vous
confronter ils étaient ni sur la liste
des morts ni sur la bbc une surréaliste
et hopitalisé il était nulle part est ce
qu'on peut vivre malgré cette douleur
quand j'ai écrit à la fois je souffrais
parce que ça me rappelait des beaux
souvenirs avec stéphane en même temps
c'était très douloureux et puis
aujourd'hui je me suis aperçu que ça
permettait d'extraire de de moi même
toute cette histoire est donc ça m'a
apporté un peu de recul un peu
d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
autrefois on parlait de vertu
aujourd'hui on préfère les scandales
[Musique]
avec nous antoine perrut de bonjour
bonjour vous êtes cio comme on disait
dans les grandes entreprises
multinationales de saint gobain russie
ukraine on a beaucoup dit que bon
l'ouest et caïcos l'eau mais que l'est
et paul bert moi je suis convaincu à des
personnels que les faut réduire les
émissions de carbone sur la planète
entière donc les plus observés il faut
réduire les émissions de carbone dans
les pays andins bien sûr partout partout
vous avez construit des usines
décarbonés pour des usines où on est
mais rien du tout comme carbone dans
l'usiné que ce soit nos émissions
directes ou alors des émissions liées à
la production d'électricité nous en
avons aujourd'hui dans le monde donc la
conscience écologique aussi existe en
russie
[Musique]
des manières
il est 21h merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire les toutes premières
discussions en face à face entre
washington et les talibans depuis la
prise de kaboul par ces derniers à la
mi-août au coeur de cet échange au qatar
les questions sécuritaires et des droits
humains en particulier l'intégration
complète des femmes et des filles dans
la société afghane demain ce sera au
tour des responsables de l'union
européenne ont entamé des pourparlers
alors les talibans sont ils vraiment
bien placé pour parler de ces
problématiques que peut-on attendre de
ces discussions à l'international
décryptage dans un instant
[Musique]
l erika les talibans se sont donc posées
autour d'une même table ce week-end au
qatar une première rencontre en face à
face depuis que les fondamentalistes ont
repris le pouvoir en afghanistan il ya
deux mois on en parle tout de suite avec
notre correspondant thomas bonnin
washington bonsoir thomas alors des
discussions plutôt franche et
professionnel selon les mots du
département d'état américain
oui c'est en effet ce qu'affirme le
communiqué publié ce week-end par le
département d'état américain à l'issue
de ces deux jours d'échangés entre
représentants américains et
représentants des talibans des échanges
qui se sont déroulés à doha au qatar le
communiqué indique que les états unis
ont mis l'accent sur la sécurité et le
terrorisme avec l'objectif de permettre
le rapatriement des ressortissants
américains toujours en afghanistan
accent qui a aussi été mis sur la
fameuse inclusivité réclamé par
washington depuis le début à l'égard des
talibans c'est aussi ce qu'a mis en
lumière ce lundi le chef de l'onu
antonio guterres est ce qui a fait part
de ses inquiétudes écoutez le
je suis particulièrement alarmés de voir
les promesses faites aux femmes et aux
filles afghanes par les talibans ne pas
être respecté les promesses non tenues
conduisent à des rêves brisés pour les
femmes et les filles d'afghanistan
alors lors des échanges qui ont eu lieu
ce week-end au qatar entre les
représentants américains et les
représentants des talibans il ya
vraisemblablement eu au moins un point
d'accord le fait que les etats-unis
puissent à moyen terme à la voir dans
les prochaines semaines acheminer de
l'aide humanitaire à destination de la
population afghane aide humanitaire qui
pourrait également contenir des doses de
vaccin contre le coronavirus on n'a en
revanche aucune autre information sur de
quelconques accord qui aurait pu être
trouvé entre les deux parties on sait en
revanche qu'il ya eu au moins un point
de désaccord puisque les représentants
des talibans ont affirmé qu'ils avaient
refusé de travailler avec les états unis
sur la lutte contre l'état islamique
estimant qu'il pouvait faire ce travail
de manière totalement indépendante alors
on rappelle qu'il s'agissait des
premiers échanges formels officielle
entre les deux parties depuis le retrait
des troupes américaines d'afghanistan à
la fin du mois d'août côté taliban on
estime que d'autres réunions pourrez
suivre ces premiers échanges d'ailleurs
vous l'avez dit il y aura demain une
autre réunion entre les représentants
des talibans et des représentants de
l'union européenne et puis côté
américain on rappelle que ces échanges
ne constituent en aucun cas une
reconnaissance officielle du
gouvernement formé par les talibans
c'est un dossier très compliqué pour
washington qui marche sur des oeufs
parce que d'un côté évidemment
washington veut garder une prise sur les
enjeux de la région montrait aussi
qu'elle n'abandonne pas les
ressortissants américains est également
les afghans qui ont travaillé avec les
américains pendant toutes ces années
qu'a duré la guerre en afghanistan et
puis de l'autre washington ne veut pas
non plus donner une trop forte
légitimité au gouvernement formé par les
talibans merci thomas bonnin en direct
de washington et après les etats-unis ce
week-end les responsables de l'union
européenne vont donc discuté à leur tour
de bras avec les talibans à doha alors
les fondamentalistes sont ils vraiment
placé pour parler des droits humains et
notamment des femmes que peut-on
attendre concrètement de ces pourparlers
c'est l'objet de notre décryptage
[Musique]
est avec nous pour en parler régis le
sommier grand reporter arte france
bonsoir sur régis merci d'être avec nous
vos côtés général dominique trinquant
expert en géostratégie ancien chef de la
mission militaire française à l'onu
bonsoir dominique trinquant et merci
d'être avec nous à vos côtés pour nous
accompagner reza jafari un président de
l'association enfants d'afghanistan
bonsoir et zafari merci aussi à vous
d'être là régis le sommier la maison
blanche qui dit désormais ne plus avoir
d'autre choix que de discuter avec ses
anciens ennemis en afghanistan ça sonne
comme un nouvel aveu d'échec de
washington je pense que l'échec il ait
lieu
l'échec il a été sept ce retrait comment
particulièrement périlleux du pays alors
que bon ça s'était déroulé les
américains toute façon avait dit depuis
longtemps qui partait il avait donné une
date butoir au départ du 11 mai qui
avait ensuite repoussé fin août on
connaît on a vu tous ces images qui ont
terni celle de l'amérique
en fait c'est presque des retrouvailles
je dirais à doha puisque les bus ne pas
oublier que les américains pendant
pratiquement 8 ans ont dialogué avec les
talibans justement essayant de jouer
cette carte de l'inclusivité sait que
c'est le mot à la mode en ce moment de
dire voilà prenez voilà comment essayons
essayer de faire un essayons puisqu'au
départ y avait quand même des
représentants de toutes les parties
d'afghanistan pendant longtemps dansé
dial discussions de doha et puis in fine
et les talibans n'ont absolument pas
respecter ce qu'ils avaient dit à part
leur accord avec l'armée américaine qui
ont été voilà
qui ont été à part de ce traité de paix
entre l'armée américaine et était libre
en deux qui date de février 2020 lui a
été respectée plus aucun américain n'a
été tué ni blessé après février 2020 et
ensuite la donc donc qui se retrouvent
ils se retrouvent avec à la clé
plusieurs choses et en particulier la
reconnaissance possible du régime
taliban et donc tout est sur la table là
on voit qu'il ya la question des femmes
on voit qu'à la question du terrorisme
la présence américaine dans la région et
je pense que c'est tout tout ça est en
gestation et à la clé pour les talibans
et la reconnaissance de leur régime joe
biden un qui expliquent enfin de
l'administration que la réelle politique
avait parfois plus forte que les
considérations intérieures vous qui
connaissez justement les arcades
notamment de l'onu ça vous inspire quoi
ces nouveaux pourparlers qui ne sont
effectivement pas pas les premiers mais
enfin on voit qu'entre temps les
promesses n'ont pas été vraiment tenu
notamment sur la composition du
gouvernement oui alors il ya trois types
de pourparlers il ya les américains avec
les talibans à doha c'est la
continuation comme vous le disiez c'est
l'application de l'accord qui a été
signé il ya un an c'est intéressant de
voir que les talibans d'ailleurs refuse
de collaborer avec les américains dans
la lutte contre des ch mais disent c'est
notre problème il faut rappeler que
c'est un des volets de l'accord de doha
à une deuxième négociation
on a vu monsieur goûter res et les
nations unies avec le conseil des droits
de l'homme qui a nommé un rapporteur
spécial pour s'occuper justement du
problème des des droits de l'homme et en
particulier de la place des femmes vous
vous rappelez que ce ceci a été proposée
par l'union européenne et donc là vous
parlez de l'union européenne qui valait
à doha c'est justement sur ce volet là
donc on voit bien qu'il ya deux volets
très distincts la sécurité globalement
c'est les américains qui s'en occupent
les droits de l'homme globalement c'est
les européens qui s'en occupe par le
biais de l'onu et aussi par le biais de
l'union européenne
résa jafari
les droits de l'homme justement vous
avez certainement en tant qu'association
des nouvelles du terrain où en est on
justement 31 août deux mois après ce
retrait américain
alors sur le plateau on entend par rza
jafari ces patients longtemps à
l'antenne voilà manifestement un petit
problème de son pardonnez nous reste à
faire et on vous entend pas on va
essayer de régler régler cela voilà
rezaï jafari apparemment on a rétabli la
connexion avec vous
alors oui je on parle de droits de
l'homme et ont parlé des talibans et les
talibans
il ya un mois j'étais en plateau sur
votre chaîne et on parlait déjà les
talibans qui avaient commencé les
tribunaux talibans qui avaient commencé
à donner les ordres d'exécution est
aujourd'hui dans le valais de peinture
on trouve des tombes où il ya des
dizaines et des dizaines de personnes
des mains attachées par derrière qui ont
été assassinés par les talibans les
déplacements
obligatoire continue
nettoyage ethnique et nettoyage
religieuse
aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup de tech
mais en y avait le gouvernement de
monsieur dany ses coûts la faute était
sur les talibans et aujourd'hui quand il
ya des attentes à la faute est sûre
d'aller chef mais il faut pas oublier
que d'aller chez al qaïda et les
talibans sont les mêmes et le hong
lors idéologique c'est le conquérir le
monde et il faut pas s'étonner que très
bientôt il y aura peut-être même une
alliance et en trio entre les talibans
d'ail hachée et aussi elle et
les talibans mais aujourd'hui vous
parler
on parle d aide humanitaire en parler
des droits de l'homme plus de 90 % des
établissements de santé sont armés
plus de 90% des populations pour être
pauvre en 2022 plus de 90 % n'ont pas
assez à manger 5 millions d'enfants
souffrent de malnutrition
18 millions de femmes sont enfermées
chez elles sont privés de tout droit de
leurs droits fondamentaux et que des
plusieurs milliers des élites
intellectuelles ont fui le pays et quel
avenir aura le pays avec en tête les
talibans aux terroristes qui sont petit
à petit en train de s'allier aux autres
groupes terroristes
jafari nous parle effectivement de ces
attentats évidemment maintenant qu'ils
sont de signer de l'état islamique c'est
un petit peu cocasse cette situation les
talibans passerait presque pour des
enfants de choeur sur place vous y
croyez à cette fameuse alliance dont pas
le raisin chef harry est surtout le fait
qu'ils poursuivent le même but donc j'ai
là et l'autre rapidement s'il vous plaît
idéologiquement si vous permettez ils
ont ils ont
les talibans qui ont combattu des ch
de façon d'ailleurs très dur notamment
dans les zones de l'est mais pas pour
des raisons idéologiques mais parce
qu'ils ont vu en des shs un groupe
concurrent un groupe rival qui a un
moment lors a pris un certain nombre de
combattants les talibans étant rentrés
justement dans ce processus de
négociations avec l'occident et au
niveau du terrain ils ont recueilli un
certain nombre d'échos en disant voilà
les talibans maintenant ça devient voilà
donc des chats a connu un certain succès
dans les zones du kunar de nangarhar à
l'est dans les ccc ccc zone d'un
gouverneur de l'est de l'afghanistan et
les talibans les ont vaincus et ils ont
utilisé cet argument d'ailleurs
vis-à-vis des américains et ils
utilisent encore aujourd'hui en disant
qu' ils vont s'en débrouiller que des ch
est toujours peuvent y va ce qu'on a vu
il ya eu notamment la semaine dernière
ce terrible attentat contre une mosquée
chiite dans la ville de koundouz et ils
les talibans disent nous on veut pas
pour le moment d'accord sur le
terrorisme je ne crois pas qu'il y aura
un accord entre des chez les talibans en
revanche ce que je sais c'est que les
talibans n'ont jamais rompu leur bail à
c'est à dire lors leur cible
l'allégeance qu'al-qaïda leur a fait a
fait au mollah omar à l'époque où il
était au pouvoir
allianz qui a permis d'ailleurs
d'accueillir ben laden et les siens en
afghanistan avec les conséquences qu'on
connaît et que les talibans n'ont pas
rompu n'ont pas souhaité rompre cette
alliance donc voilà maintenant dèche
c'est un peu différent des cheveux vous
dis a été combattue comme un groupe
terroriste
et comme un groupe concurrent par les
talibans est aujourd'hui des shs entend
bien déstabiliser les talibans je citais
cet attentat
juste là dessus l'attentât de koundouz a
été perpétré par un combattant de dèche
ouigours c'est à dire de la minorité
musulmane chinoise donne de chine on
connaît les relations entre les chinois
est ce que font les chinois ouïghours en
ce moment il y avait un message clair
aussi puisque les deux les chinois eux
sont alliés avec les talibans donc tout
ça c'est un jeu mais en tout cas des
chais toujours présent et pour le moment
je vois pas d'alliance entre des chez
les talibans au contraire
sont des éléments de de négociations je
répète les américains vont négocier sur
la sécurité que les talibans lutte
contre des ch c'est un élément en faveur
des talibans pour la négociation avec
les américains donc c'est un élément de
négociation de même que lorsqu'on parle
des droits de l'homme est évidemment que
tout ce qui se passe là-bas avec les
talibans est
abominable mais c'est aussi un argument
de négociation avec l'union européenne
je rappelle qu'aujourd'hui en
afghanistan ils n'ont pas le choix tout
est coupé tous les robinets sont fermés
donc s'ils veulent faire venir de l'aide
humanitaire s'ils veulent avoir de
l'argent il va falloir qu'il donne
quelque chose en échange parce que quand
on l'écouterait zafari voilà il ya aussi
surtout beaucoup de souffrance humaine
sur place ne surent pas que des
négociations entre grandes puissances à
l'onu il ya voilà des gens qui mais si
on s'en sort quel avenir pour ce pays
mais justement c'est un argument de
négociation les les talibans avec l'est
la situation terrible qui a là bas il
regarde et vous allez aggraver encore la
situation est donc donnée nous
l ont été
il ya eu des des commandes et projet il
ya des petits filets iavi notifie les
fumées attendait c'est l'hiver qui
arrive c'est l'hiver qui arrive donc
c'est une catastrophe humanitaire donc
il faut ré ouvrir tous les robinets et
ce site sur paris ouvert on commence les
négociations et naturellement les
talibans comme sur la sécurité négocier
avec les américains la prise en compte
de dèche avec les européens et l'onu ils
vont négocier les droits de l'homme et
une certaine incertaine sous plissement
on verra les tout le monde dira on aime
bien les discours mais on veut voir les
actes 1 on va voir les actes en échange
d'une aide humanitaire massive parce
qu'il faut une aide humanitaire massive
il est tout de même assez sachs même
s'il ya beaucoup évidemment de de
cynisme on imagine pour vous dans cette
affaire
alors
c'est alors juste pour terminer
aujourd'hui dans le nord d'afghanistan
il ya quelques jours on avait une
discussion
d'aller chez en train d'armer ceux qui
veulent combattre les talibans et tout à
l'heure vous avez parlé ligoure
mission utilisé aussi par des ch
pourquoi je dis qu'il ya une possible
alliance est avec qaïda et les talibans
parce qu'ils ont les mêmes idéologies et
que par par le passé en afghanistan même
s'ils ont combattu
des chez les talibans ils ont mené des
opérations
ensemble plusieurs fois
notamment lors les attaques les
maternités à kaboul d'acheter parti en
vue pour les aides humanitaires ce que
nous en demande et les associations et
les ong on demande à halloween mandanda
internationale de soutenir surtout le
peuple de soutenir les ong pour que les
et puisse aller directement à la
population n'est pas aux talibans on n'a
aucune garantie que les talibans ont
distribué ces aides et en plus de plus
on négocie avec les éléments plus on
leur donne la légitimité à chaque fois
qu'on a négocié avec les talibans ils
n'ont jamais respecté aucun accord
jamais jamais aujourd'hui c'est vrai
qu'ils attaquent pas les étrangers en
afghanistan mais il faut savoir qu'il
n'ya pas vraiment l'étranger ou des
forces étrangères en afghanistan
quand on parle de respecter les accords
sinon ils ont respecté aucun accord et
aujourd'hui il faut pas de nom bientôt
demain il y aura une discussion avec
elle l'europe on répète encore une fois
comme on parle avec les gens sur place
malgré toute cette souffrance ils ne
veulent pas vivre ce que la reine des
talibans et qu'il dise plus en discuter
et négocier avec les talibans plus on
donne la légimité et on va vers une
reconnaissance de gouvernement des
talibans ce qui va être une vraie
vraiment
pardonnez moi je mangeais distribuer un
petit peu la parole vous êtes tous très
bavard ça me fait plaisir mais enfin je
suis obligé de me voilà d'arbitrer un
peu général sera qu'en wi c'est vrai
plus on discute plus on donne de la
légitimité
les états unis demain l'europe après
demain moscou les humanitaires qu'elle
arrive par le biais des ong moi je veux
bien mais ils négocieront avec les
talibans sans accord avec les talibans
rien n'arrivera et donner l'aide
humanitaire aux angie on connaît le
travail des ong remarquable sur le
terrain mais ils sont obligés de
négocier avec les talibans donc voilà et
il faut négocier des deux côtés de façon
à obtenir des talibans deux des droits
de l'homme et des droits des femmes
surtout en échange on donne de l'aide
humanitaire qu'on va peut-être faire
transiter par les ong mais qui elle
aussi négocieront sur le terrain avec
les talibans il n'y a pas d'autres
moyens
moi si je vais revenir sur une situation
la plus critique en afghanistan
aujourd'hui ces eaux là où il ya
peut-être un levier que la communauté
internationale peut faire jouer c'est
précisément ce qu'on a décrit mais dans
les détails c'est encore pire que ce
qu'on peut imaginer la situation là il
ya une grosse partie de la population
afghane qui à risque de famine
aujourd'hui j'ai eu des nouvelles du
côté de bamiyan notamment où les gens
ont quasiment plus rien à bouffer et que
disons que l'hiver arrive comme on le
disait donc là il ya une situation
extrêmement critique et dans les
hôpitaux on le voit aussi dont on a vu
quand même des quelques images assez
effrayante de nourrissons arrivons
complètement décharné dans certains
endroits et est là
les talibans ne peuvent pas se permettre
ils peuvent on sait qu'ils sont capables
d'imposer un ordre c'est qu'ils sont
capables d'imposer leur loi leur charia
et tout ce qui est venu avec mais en
réalité c'était pas dans leur intérêt
d'avoir cette famine qui se déclare et
que la communauté internationale peut
obtenir
c'est pas un chantage mais peut obtenir
quand même certains certains
aménagements parce que ils savent très
bien les discussions avec l'europe les
droits de l'homme oui mais ils savent
très bien qu il ya des pays qui peuvent
aidée notamment l'allemagne les talibans
d'ailleurs ont pris contact directement
avec les allemands sans passer par
l'europe donc ils savent que ici le rôle
s'ils veulent s'installer ils ont
attendu vingt ans pour reprendre le
pouvoir ils n'ont pas l'intention de le
quitter or les afghans ce sont des gens
qui peuvent être très versatile il ya
certains il ya une certaine adhésion
d'une certaine partie de la population à
l'idéologie talibane si les talents ne
sont pas le boulot ils peuvent être
aussi l'objet il peut y avoir des
dérives des révoltes en afghanistan une
opposition qui s'arme des seigneurs de
guerre qui change de camp etc etc c'est
toujours c'est une possibilité donc là
il ya un moment critique et il ya un
moment où il me semble la communauté
internationale peut justement faire
changer et peut-être faire évoluer les
choses oui oui non simplement pour dire
les les talibans doivent réussir pour
eux mêmes ils doivent réussir
aujourd'hui et pour réussir les données
en viennent d'être exprimées il va
falloir qu'ils cèdent un certain nombre
de choses alors ils essayent de façon
maligne passé par l'allemagne pas passer
par l'europe ça ne marchera pas
l'allemagne restera dans le groupe
européen pour arriver à faire poids face
aux talibans résa jafari quand vous
entendez parce qu'on a on parle beaucoup
on aura évidemment
forcément de l'opposition de deux voilà
de massoud du commandant massoud mais il
ya une partie aussi de la population qui
adhère aux talibans à ce que ça vous le
constaterez tout de même vous aussi avec
les nouvelles que vous avez du terrain
alors c'est vrai qu'il ya une partie de
la population qui adhère j'ai
allaité régime des talibans parce que
ils sont obliger
certaines traces ans mais aujourd'hui la
plupart des gens qui s'en allait des
nouvelles que nous on a des terrains
aujourd'hui et l'alliance du nord ce
n'est pas qu'aux dans le valais des
peintures mais aussi un portrait partout
en afghanistan les chefs de guerre de
plus en plus
[Musique]
s'organise les chefs de guerre avec qui
et qui s'entend dans les pays est
limitrophe et qui s'organisait tout à
l'heure et une fois que la famine touche
est vraiment que la population et une
fois que les talibans n'arrive pas
vraiment à la diriger le pays et à
satisfaire les besoins de la population
il va et puis avoir soit en soulèvement
national et tt chaque côté et dans le
nord vous avez le fils le commandant
massoud et met de son côté aussi général
de cet homme qui était à un cheveu gars
très puissant mais dans le sud il ya des
mouvements de résistance et qui se
créent aussi mais il ya beaucoup
beaucoup
d'afghans mais qui sont prêts à aider
financièrement ses résistances mais
aussi peut-être autrement
merci en tout cas à tous les trois résa
jafari léger sommier je vais bien dormir
encore merci d'avoir été avec nous
et avant de refermer cette émission
petit détour par la république tchèque
le pays est plongé dans l'incertitude
après l'hospitalisation du président
milosevic le chef de l'état qui doit
désigner le futur premier ministre une
nomination est un destin politique
suspendus pour leur série et le bruit
une ambulance scruté par tout un pays
hospitalisé ce dimanche le président
tchèque milos zeman a été admis en soins
intensifs
un retour à l'hôpital inquiétant pour le
chef de l'état âgé de 77 ans quelques
semaines seulement après sa dernière
admission dans le tas mais avec un
renard maire et je vous informe que
après 13 heures le président miloche
zeman a été hospitalisée sur ma
recommandation
la raison de cette hospitalisation ce
sont les complications dues à sa maladie
chronique pour laquelle il est traité
dans notre hôpital cela signifie que
nous connaissons exactement le
diagnostic est que nous pouvons orienter
le traitement en conséquence ça va je
vous tends créac'h marley pas là une
hospitalisation qui complique un peu
plus l'avenir politique du pays en
république tchèque la fonction
présidentielle est principalement
cérémoniel mais le chef de l'état tient
un rôle clé dans la mise en place de
chaque nouveau gouvernement
plus tôt dans la journée me l'offre
émane avait reçu le premier ministre
sortant andrei babiche au lendemain des
élections législatives malgré sa courte
défaite face à l'alliance de
centre-droit ensemble le milliardaire
garde l'espoir d'un maintien au pouvoir
aller
au japon c'est vrai que nous ne pensions
pas que nous allions perdre je tiens à
féliciter le vice président de la
chambre des députés fiala pour son
excellent résultat qui est évidemment
fantastique
c'est le fruit d'une grande mobilisation
au mime beaucoup tu n'es pas
si le président me charge de former un
gouvernement je contacterai la coalition
et bien entendu nous parlerons aussi
avec d'autres à l'exception du parti
pirate
en effet si la coalition menée par petr
fiala a remporté les législatives ce
samedi rien n'est gagné pour autant
avant la publication des résultats milos
zeman avait laissé entendre qu'il
pourrait choisir de laisser andrei
babiche au poste de chef du gouvernement
une décision qui pourrait déplaire à la
population tchèque à l'image de certains
citoyens qui se réjouissent déjà de la
défaite du premier ministre sortant
[Musique]
je suis absolument enthousiastes parce
que c'est un retour à la politique que
nous connaissons depuis des années 90
et à toutes les bonnes choses que nous
avons commencé en novembre 1989
nous devons poursuivre dans cette voie
pour suivre la décence la démocratie
approfondir nos liens avec l'union
européenne et l'otan
je suis heureux en fait et maintenant je
me demande comment les choses vont se
passer il y aura des pourparlers donc
nous verrons ce qu'ils vont négocier
honnêtement je ne sais pas vraiment à
quoi m'attendre mais je suppose que les
baby ce vont tenter un gouvernement
minoritaire et il est difficile de dire
s'il s'en sortiront nous verrons il est
également difficile de dire ce que fera
le président car son rôle est crucial
maintenant nous verrons bien
la république tchèque reste donc
suspendu au sort de son président reste
à savoir si le chef de l'etat sera en
mesure d'honorer un rendez vous officiel
avec son premier ministre sortant
la rencontre est prévue ce mercredi et
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir suivi rendez vous demain dès 20
heures d'ici là n'oubliez pas de réagir
de commenter poser vos questions sur le
télégramme d'ayrté france prochain point
sur l'actualité dans une trentaine de
minutes et toute la soirée sur air
france
[Musique]
les valeurs de la république doivent
être défendus quand certains jouent la
carte du séparatisme
[Musique]
avec nous antoine perrut de bonjour
bonjour vous êtes cio comme on dit dans
les grandes entreprises multinationales
de saint gobain russie ukraine on a
beaucoup dit que bon
l'ouest était écolo mais que l'est et
paul bert moi je suis convaincue at et
personnel que il faut réduire les
émissions de carbone sur la planète
entière donc les plus observés aux îles
il faut réduire les émissions de carbone
dans les pays hors de l'ue bien sûr
partout partout vous avez construit des
vignes décarbonés pour des usines où on
est mais rien du tout comme carbone dans
l usine que ce soit nos émissions
directes ou alors des émissions liées à
la production d'électricité nous en
avons aujourd'hui dans le monde donc la
conscience écologique aussi existe en
russie
[Musique]